as a final season of Game of Thrones
came to a close there were plenty of
characters left behind surprisingly not
all of them are dead just forgotten more
fan favorite sports off the long night
and rode around on Dragons long before
sparks flew between Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen the Dragon Queen had
another lover and we're not talking
about the dearly departed Khal Drogo
Daario naharis was a one-time a
lieutenant of a cell sword company
called the second sons who proved his
loyalty to Dany by killing his
commanders and taking control of the
group in her name why because he had a
big old crush on the breaker of chains
we had philosophical differences over
what your beauty it meant more to me
than it did to them as Dany and her army
took over the cities of slavers Bay
Daario got more and more flirty
eventually earning himself a place in
her bed as a queen however Danny's
marriage would have to be a political
one so as much as Dario's pretty boy
looks amused her
Dany never quite returned his affection
this is why she left him behind an
s-class to help rule in her stead
breaking her ties with him at Tyrians
prompting and leaving Daario lovesick on
another continent for the events of the
final season which probably worked out
for the best remember back when the most
heartbreaking thing about Game of
Thrones was a scene straight out of Old
Yeller back in season 1 and when Arya
was somehow even smaller than she is now
she and Sansa got along about as well as
cats and dogs but they both love their
overgrown direwolf puppies they were
heartbroken when Sun Tzu's wolf lady was
put down and arias Namir was sent away
after justifiably biting Prince Joffrey
each of the stark children had their own
dire wolf at one point most of coming to
the same tragic fate of their masters as
of the last episode goes to still alive
finally getting the pets he deserved
from Jon Snow and somewhere in the
Riverlands Nymeria is still out there
hunting Arya run into the now wild dire
wolf and a newfound pack on her way back
to Winterfell
[Music]
I'm area as cool as it would have been
for Aria to have returned home with both
sick assassin skills and the giant wolf
by Mary Eyre had her own family now as
much as she wanted to Aria wasn't about
to take her away from them without me
reread bran would have made it back to
Winterfell in order to reveal the great
big secret of the series Meera was tough
as nails and an uncanny archer while she
was unable to save her brother from
dying at the hands of the whites she
does deserve a few points for patiently
sitting in a creepy cold cave drawing
brands trips into the past shattering a
white Walker with a spear and getting
the three-eyed Raven back to Winterfell
in one piece in the end though the only
thing she gets from bran is a blank look
and a half-hearted thank you my brother
died for you how Doran summer died for
you I almost died for you understandably
frustrated mirror reminds bran of all
the people who sacrifice themselves to
hold the door and save him of course in
response he counters that bran stark did
die long live the three-eyed Raven after
all that Meera finally goes home taking
a well-deserved rest and staying out of
the ensuing drama of the final season in
a rather controversial cameo a British
pop sensation ed Sheeran appeared as a
soldier during the seventh season
sharing a fireside meal with Arya and
treating her to a song actress Maisie
Williams was apparently more than a
little star-struck but alas shirin's
character wasn't destined to stick
around when his character Eddy appeared
he was part of the Lannister forces sent
to the Riverlands after arias brutal
assassination of Lord Walder Frey and
most of his house unfortunately for
Eddie we know that those in golden red
armor eventually met with a fiery fate
on the gold road when Danny
the Dothraki and drogon absolutely
destroyed them in battle
remember those eerie shots of men
turning to ash endure the incredible
heat of Dragon Fire poor ed sheeran
probably ruined his singing voice
screaming for his life the good news
thanks to a conversation about Eddie the
ginger in season eights first episode we
do know that he survived his encounter
with dragon just not in a particularly
pleasant way came back with his face
burnt right off
he's got no eyelids now of all the minor
characters in Game of Thrones not as
beloved as hot pie who earned his
nickname with baking skills that are
almost as legendary as Arya's ability to
get revenge he made our hero
of adorable slightly malformed the
direwolf bread before she departed with
the hound and stole her heart with kerbs
an aria returned to Westeros in season 7
she briefly returned with hot pie at the
crossroads n after thoroughly enjoying a
few tasty treats he got our year up to
speed on all the big news like how Jon
Snow's somehow became king in the north
which was one of the reasons why she
ultimately decided to return to
Winterfell which led directly to her
saving the entire world which isn't a
bad contribution to the series she does
give him one piece of solid advice
before she leaves though take care of
yourself up I try not to eat killed hawa
I'm not you arey I'm a survivor fighting
the dead and taking on evil Queens
aren't exactly playing to its skill set
so it makes sense that we don't see him
return in season 8
but hey hot pie might be the only person
in Westeros who actually got a normal
job at the end of all this check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and at the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]